حضاره باكملها غيبها الزلزال في تركيا
فالدمار سيد المشهد لم تختلف في الصوره في
سوريا كلاهما تنعيان اجزاء واسعه من
مدنهما هنا يبرز السؤال كيف سيتم التعامل
مع مخلفات الزلازل من تلال الركام واقوام
الحجاره خاصه في المدن المكتظه بالمباني
التي لم تصمد في وجه تلك الهزات الارضيه
فالعمليه تشكل تحديا كبيرا مع وجود عدد
ضخم من الانقاض يشمل الطوب والخرسانه
والاثاثه والممتلكات الشخصيه الخطوه
الاولى تبدا بتنظيف الشوارع والاماكن
العامه من المكدسات عبر الجرافات
والرافعات للسماح لفرق الانقاذ ومنظمه
الاغاثه بالتحرك بحريه وبمجرد ازاله
العوائق عن الطرق يتم التركيز على المباني
نفسها وتقييم الاضرار للتفريق بين الصالح
الصالح منها ثم ياتي دور المهندسين
فيحددون استنادا لاستقرار الهياكل اي
العماره يمكن اعاده تشييدها وايها يجب
هدمه فاذا كان المبنى غير امن وجب التخلص
منه واذا ما تحدثنا عن الردم سيتعين على
العاملين جمع الانقاض ونقلها الى مكب
النفايات المخصص او مرافق اعاده التدوير
وبانتقاء الخيار الصديق للبيئه ستكون
المهمه مكلفه وصعبه وطويله ولكن بالتاكيد
هي الافضل في تقليل النفايات
وبشكل مجمل وبعد هذا الخراب الذي تخلفه
الزلازل بدقائق وايام معدوده يبقى التحدي
الاكبر هو كيفيه التنسيق بين الوكالات
الحكوميه والمنظمات الانسانيه والخاصه لان
التعافي قد يمتد من شهور الى سنوات
اسراء الصغير العربيه
[موسيقى]